health officials fear Americans
traveling for this weekend's religious
holidays could worsen the growing
measles outbreak the CDC says there are
at least 555 confirmed cases in 20
states most are said to involve
school-aged kids a judge in New York
dismissed a lawsuit yesterday that
challenged an emergency declaration
requiring residents of certain hard-hit
neighborhoods to get vaccinated Molla
legi is in Brooklyn New York where he
spoke with a mother who is part of the
suit all a good morning good morning
while the mandatory vaccinations are
still in effect the criminal penalties
have been removed from the order the
city has issued civil summonses for
fines up to $1,000 to three families in
New York City for failing to vaccinate
their children the only way to stop this
outbreak is to ensure that those who
have not been vaccinated get the vaccine
while New York City is facing the
largest measles outbreak in the country
the measles vaccine works this is
against the Civil Rights Act some
parents are suing the city over an order
to ban unvaccinated people from public
places
this is 2019 we should not be having to
be forced to hide from our government
the outbreak is centered around the
highly concentrated ultra-orthodox
Jewish communities in Williamsburg where
more than 250 cases have been reported
in the last seven months they said we
won't be bullied these were very brave
people who came forward attorney Robert
Krakow represents the families in the
suit we're all for the appropriate
measures to control an outbreak of
disease but New Yorkers are not going to
accept
criminal penalties for vaccinations
that's not appropriate people have a
right to make their choice the city has
ordered people over the age of six
months who live or go to school in parts
of Williamsburg to get vaccinated or
face a $1,000 fine and in Rockland
County those infected with measles must
avoid public places and stay in their
homes for 21 days failure to comply can
result in a fine of $2,000 per violation
per day this is about
and medical freedom one of the parents
involved in the suit who did not want
her identity revealed says it's not
about religion but her rights and
believes she's doing what's best for her
child I teach my child that our bodies
are our own we can say when and where
yes and no whether it's in the workplace
or in an intimate moment that doesn't
stop because the government says you
have to do X Y or Z now the mother I
spoke with says she cares very much
about the health of other children but
believes that hers is also healthy and
would not expose her child if they were
not healthy
on Wednesday the Washington State Senate
passed a measure that would remove an
option parents have to not vaccinate
their children against measles mumps and
rubella John MOA thank you